wow 20 21. are you t-pain bro
no ma'am that's my cousin though we're
here at rolling loud the number one
hip-hop festival in
the world and obviously we're talking to
people about money and we want to know
if hip-hop is good or bad for your
wallet
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money what are you doing
out here today
i'm looking to have a good time shake
some ass
shake some ass respect having a good
time yes the concert for sure
i just want to see a bunch of performers
that have come out in the last like few
years that i haven't seen yet how much
would you say you guys spent all in
being here
damn near 5000. we don't want to check
our bank accounts right now
1500 probably two grand a thousand
probably eight hundred
eight grand six hundred i'm very
fortunate i got rich cousins i'm not
gonna lie
like i probably spend like a hundred
bucks you guys you got a rich family
this guy's definitely gonna buy you a
drink jennifer who are you most excited
to see her today asap rocky
megan the [ __ ] stallion gucci mane
travis scott
post malone and the [ __ ]
stallion
megan the stallion post malone post
malone
of obviously the only reason i bought a
ticket i heard kanye's supposed to be
here today right ooh
kanye where do you guys get your
financial advice from nobody i've been a
boss
she's been a boss jesus i hope jesus all
right what does jesus teach you about
money
um to just spend it and it's going to
come back
credit is king not cash tick tock tick
tock has a good source
my family from my mom nobody really i
just make my own money and do whatever i
want with it
my parents my older brother my boss and
obviously me i receive pretty shitty
advice i'm not gonna lie
to my mom what's the best advice your
family your mom's ever given you
save and invest go to law school save
have your [ __ ] paycheck
have your money work as hard for you as
you work to earn it how's it feel being
a rolling lab brother
feels amazing thank you for having me i
appreciate it what are you most excited
about here
i'm most excited about seeing all my
friends all the other cool artists
that are doing great and making money
and being rich
best financial advice you give to kids
out here make sure you work on your
credit that's important
if you expect to be rich make sure your
credit is on point thank you brother if
you could pick
one rapper to manage your money who you
picking
asap rocky okay tell me what
i don't know little baby because you
know how to hit yeah you know how to
handle it the baby knows what's up
kanye for real
the baby i feel he's got a family he
provides her
jacob j cole yj cole you notice how like
he's one of the few rappers that doesn't
be dripped out in all these chains dr
dre
now i had to be young thug have you seen
his outfits no tell me
honestly young thug got so many chains i
need him to get me together rick ross he
got the bose
real estate business assets although
polly drake
soldier boy because he created
everything first bro travis scott that's
a tough one
uzi oh i don't trust him
good answer a little baby honestly
probably the amigos like they got so
much money
50 cent post malone oh my god definitely
offset because
he is so good he invests in everything
like he actually knows about stocks
who's the last person on your list you'd
want to get financial advice from
probably cardi b because she'd make me
spend all of it
kanye west nine he's no bueno no bueno
you're my man lil uzi
he bought a [ __ ] planet bro ain't
nobody need that he's investing in
planets
because he put that dumb ass dabbing in
his head he didn't like the diamond in
his forehead okay no pump
kodak black black kodak i feel like
kodak black would just
kodak kodak there's a video of him
throwing money in the water i don't know
another kodak all right kodak we don't
want kodak managing our money
mchammer scammer maybe the best answer
all day was a multi-millionaire now he's
broke
if i gave you guys 10 g's right now what
are you doing with it
buy some stocks i can do a lot with 10g
i'm about heavily [ __ ] steroids
clearly you've already spent some money
on it bro alcohol
i'm buying my mama a house i'll probably
go to the bahamas like invest in real
estate buying tickets to coachella
strippers and blow babies i'm gonna
invest that into myself into my business
save and invest i start my clothing
brand i would give 10 percent of it to a
good cause
property management i buy my own
building create some liquid income like
we all about our money saving the
tickets for the next rolling loud i'm
traveling
invested in my music use it towards my
tuition i would probably just
immediately ask my dad what i should do
with it
i'm like he would know better than me
i'm paying off my car because i just
crashed it actually all right
we've been looking to get a place
together in houston he's got a great
attitude by the way you want to keep
this girl i would definitely want to get
a house yeah
if you could have a boyfriend who's
super paid
tons of money but horrible personality
or hilarious awesome guy broke as hell
no money
who would you pick good i mean
personality
money all the way what were you going to
say first
person oh my god personality looks fade
money lasts forever ooh
if you spend it wisely you're an only
fans girl tell us about only fans what's
so good about it only fans is kind of
crazy
how much money can you make a year doing
only fans between 150 to 500k a year
why does only fans get a bad name
society is too scared about sex like
nobody wants to talk about it but
everybody's doing it
are you guys comfortable with being
labeled as sex workers
yes i'm a sex worker a sex worker i'm a
sexy sex worker
final piece of advice to the broke boys
out there if they want to get pretty
girls like you
don't get an independent girl if you
can't handle her just make sure you work
hard and get that money
maybe i can see you in five years five
years wait your time baby
last question here we go save that money
or spend that money
you got to spend it because you could
save somebody else's money for later oh
save it i'm flipping that [ __ ] depends
on the [ __ ] and it depends on the time
of the day
tomorrow not promised okay save your
money because it will save you
reinvest so spend it i'd save it invest
it get more and then spend it on rolling
loud how about you
save it except for the ship for rolling
loud for now guys so save it but spend
it on rolling loud
invest that money spend it because uh
money make you happy
save it because i don't got no money
can i give you a hug for some reason i
feel like you deserve a hug okay
all right have a great time
i needed this attention hi
and i'll tell you this don't judge the
gen z book by its cover
for the most part i was pleasantly
surprised by the overall financial
know-how
at a hip-hop festival yeah spend your
money on what you truly enjoy
but the overall vibe will save up so you
can invest in yourself
and in appreciating assets you know the
drill
save that money all we talk is money all
we talk is money
all we talk is money